a Christian school is defending its
decision to discipline a pregnant
student heritage Academy in Western
Maryland ban Maddie Runkles from
participating in her graduation ceremony
next month the anti-abortion group
students for life says the school should
not punish this 18 year old teenager Jan
Crawford is in Washington she spoke with
a high school senior Jan good morning
well good morning so you know in many
ways Maddie Runkles was a model student
she got straight A's this year she was
president of the student council and she
admits she made a mistake she says she
considered having an abortion but she
decided against it and now she says
punishment she's facing isn't fair this
wasn't going to be the way that I um had
ever planned it to go so it's not what
you dreamed hey Maddie Runkles knew
she'd have to put her college plans on
hold and face consequences at her
Christian high school after learning she
was pregnant did you think I could have
an abortion mmm definitely you're taught
that it's wrong and you know that it's
wrong um I never thought that I
considered but it was just the fear and
what I've seen girls like me go through
instead she confided in her mother
Sharon Wow a teen and a mom and then the
next thought that went through my head
is how are we gonna get her through her
senior year students at heritage Academy
signed a pledge which includes a promise
for abstaining from sexual immorality
school officials suspended Runkles for
two days and removed her from leadership
roles in student organizations they also
banned her from walking in her
graduation ceremony next month so it's
just dragging out my punishments
continual punishment what did you think
the punishment should have been just
what happened to the other kids who
broke the student code
this was my nine week ultrasound she
claims she's willing to accept the
consequences that says other students
who break their pledge aren't being held
at a graduation the family reached out
to the anti-abortion group students for
life which warrants this could be a
turning point causing many students to
turn away from the pro-life and
Christian message this is for Maddie
this is for her principal Dave Hobbs
sent a letter to parents saying the
school is pleased that she has chosen
not to abort her son but that she was
immoral by not abstaining he explains
the school's teachings are grounded in
religion she has fallen short of what's
described in the mission state but does
that make sense
as God's plan for their lives as
Christian leaders write discipline he
says is handled on a case-by-case basis
with Runkles case being a compromise as
some people wanted to expel her we love
Maddie we forgive her we want her to be
viewed as part of the heritage family
but there's still accountability
necessary she has more guts than I had
at 45 years old to walk into school
every day to take the criticism that she
takes and to take it was grace that she
takes it with and she's got it together
and I think she's going to be fine
how would you describe what you've gone
through it's been a blessing because I
was saying yeah I know at the end of the
day that I made the right choice in a
couple months I'll have this little
sweet reward just to remind me that I
did the right thing now Maddie Runkles
has still been able to attend classes
and she will get her diploma she just
won't be able to walk with her 14 other
classmates now the baby's father by the
way is not a student at the school and
the baby boy is due in September Maddie
said that she's planning to name him
Grayson that's a nod to God's grace and
forgiveness Nora Jan thank you well no
doubt this story will engender a lot of
opinions on both sides lots of
conversation I was glad Jan let us know
about the baby's father because I was
thinking does he get to walk but he's
not a student at the school so it's a
non-issue there and an element of the
Christian message is forgiveness House